>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Sonya Lee: Good afternoon.
I think it's 12:01.
So we're going to start the
program because she has a lot
of things to cover and then
want to talk to you about.
So, good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen.
Good to see you all.
My name is Sonya Lee,
Korea Reference Specialist
at the Asian Division,
Library of Congress.
Today's lecture is
for the Moral Science
in Postwar North Korea
by Dr. Dafna Zur.
So Dr. Dafna Zur is assistant
professor in the Department
of East Asian Languages
and Cultures
at the Stanford University.
She teaches course
on Korean literature,
cinema and popular culture.
Her book, "Figuring Korean
Futures: Children's Literature
in Modern Korea" published by
the Stanford University Press
in 2017, traced the
effective investment
and quoted aspiration
made possible
by children's literature in
colonial and postcolonial Korea.
She has published
numerous articles
on North Korean science
fiction, Korean War in North
and South Korean children's
literature, and children
in cinema and Korean
popular culture.
So now without further ado,
please give a big
welcome to Dr. Dafna Zur.
[ Applause ]
>> Dafna Zur: All right.
Well, thank you all so
much for being here.
This is the fanciest
venue I've ever spoken at.
And I think from now
on, it's just going
to be downhill for me.
So I'm going to try
and just, you know,
milk it for what it's worth.
Thank you to my dear
friend, Sonya Lee,
who has worked tirelessly
for all these years
to make this Korean
collection just
such a fantastic collection.
It should be kind of a
world destination as far
as I'm concerned for
anyone who is interested
in North Korean especially
Cold War period.
And of course, to all, thank you
to all the guests today, my aunt
and uncle are here,
as well as friends.
And I'm just so honored today
to be speaking with you today
and to have a chance
to introduce my work.
So what I'm going to do today
is to briefly introduce some
of the materials that we have
here at the Library of Congress.
In fact, I have a slide.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about how we study North Korea.
Those of us who are
studying especially--
and from my historical
perspective, what are the tools,
how do we go about doing that?
I'm going to then talk about the
Library of Congress collection
and what it has to offer.
And lastly, I'm going to
talk about my own interest
in North Korean science
and science fiction
and tell you a little bit about
how I came to study this topic
and I will end with a
little bit more sort
of in-detail examination
and share with you some
of my recent findings.
So how do we study North Korea?
I mean, this may seem like a
very simple question but many
of us can't travel
there including myself.
I have not been to North Korea.
A lot of my-- as I was telling
this one before, a lot of the--
my European colleagues in fact
go quite frequently there,
of course also limited
into the kind of materials
that I-- they have access to.
But we can't go, right.
And we don't have
access to their archives,
whatever those might look like.
We also can't do what we
call fieldwork or we can't go
and interview people or
get a sense of, you know,
how people live and
how they interact.
So much of our knowledge
is built
through printed materials,
right.
We try and get as much access
to a broad range of materials,
magazines, newspapers,
leaflets, school textbooks,
whatever we can get
our hands on basically,
to try and piece
together a sense of kind
of the lived reality and
that, you know, on the ground
in North Korea, you know.
So we-- everything
is fascinating
and everything can
really help us, you know,
from literary sources to popular
sources, specialized, general,
anything we can get
helps build this kind
of more complete picture
of North Korea for those
of us working on this
historical period.
So I want to talk a little
bit about what the range
of materials out there are.
So one of the big sources
or the important sources
that have served a lot
of the historians working
on North Korea are the-- what's
called the captured documents
that are held in the National
Archives, that were collected
by the US Army during
the Korean War.
And these archives--
I myself have not been
to those archives and seen them.
I have talked to a lot of
my colleagues who have.
They're basically boxes and
boxes of papers that were taken
by the US military
during the Korean War.
They sit there and historians
go and they just sort of try
and piece together this very
chaotic kind of archive.
And so that archive has served
as a foundation for studies
of history for example
by Professor Suzy Kim
from Rutgers University,
Professor Charles Armstrong
from Columbia University
are a few
and also I'm sure
there's a couple of books.
So these archives in--
the National Archives have
really served to create a kind
of a foundation for
understanding what was going
on on the ground in
North Korea in the 1950s.
But as I said, they're very,
very-- as I understand,
they're very chaotic, you know,
these are loose papers lying
in boxes and you have to kind of
really spend a long time trying
to make sense of them.
The next kind of source that we
have are former Soviet archives.
So, you know, this is,
you know, I always think
if I could do it all again, I
would learn Russian and Korean,
as well as, you know,
many other languages.
There's never enough time.
But my colleagues who
have traveled to Moscow--
I'm going there in May, so
I'm very excited about that,
but there's a national library
there with great archives.
I have colleagues
working, you know,
in other former Soviet
languages that have access
to foreign service
documents, and so on.
So those are also really
great places to mine
for documents relating to
early North Korea, 1950s,
1945 to 1955, 1960, et cetera.
And we have also-- I did say
before that it's hard for us
to travel to North Korea and
talk to North Koreans but,
you know, as we know, there are
increasing number of defectors
that are settling-- most of
them are settling in South Korea
but a lot of them also find
their way to the United States
and to other countries
in the world.
And they are very
important sources
for understanding what
life is like at the moment.
There are some challenges
with these oral histories,
mostly that there are not that
many defectors and they are--
they have what we call
interview fatigue.
They can often get, you
know, interviewed by many,
many number of journalists,
of scholars, anthropologists,
people working on North Korea.
And so it's, you know, they're--
We don't have enough of a range.
Also a lot of the
defectors do tend to come
from let's say Pyongyang.
They come from a certain class.
And so they do give insights
into certain place and time
but their-- the range can
be a little bit limited.
So oral histories are important
and they're getting done
but they also are not--
cannot give at this
time a complete picture.
And lastly, the published
materials that we can find
in library collections
around the world.
So I mentioned Moscow before.
Many of you may be surprised
or not surprised to know
that South Korea
actually does not have a--
Oh gosh, I'm being recorded.
Their collection is more
limited, shall we say?
And it may not be surprising to
those of you who know something
about South Korean laws and the
way that there has just been--
the access to North Korea has
been really, really limited
in South-- limited
in South Korea.
So right now, the only place
that you can get access
to North Korean printed
materials in South Korea is
on the fifth floor of
the Seodaemun doseogwan
which is the main library or
the central library in Seoul.
You go in there, you-- Well,
and much like the Library
of Congress, I guess.
Well, actually, you have
to give your passport.
You have-- they take down all
your personal information.
They want to know
exactly who is coming in
and out of that library.
And their collections tend
to be a little bit
more limited in scope.
They have a lot more,
I think, sort of 1980s,
post 1980s materials, some
from the '60s and '70s.
But that's a much more
kind of limited collection.
In United States, I
would say the two biggest
or the largest collections
are at Harvard,
at the Yenching library, and
by far, this wonderful library,
the Library of Congress.
And so, as I said-- And I
actually don't know as much
about the history
of this archive.
Maybe Sonya Lee can
fill me in later
or maybe add to the discussion.
But what I know is
that we have here
in the Asian reading room just
down the hall, 274 journals
from North Korea,
going all the way back
to what we call the
liberation space of 1945.
It is the largest collection
of North Korean serials
from the 1940s to 1960s, so
really the most exciting,
as far as I'm concerned,
period of North Korean history,
including recent
publications of North Korea.
So it's not only a
historical archive.
It's also very, very current.
And so, next slide.
And even more exciting,
just as of, I think,
a couple of days ago, it
has been made known to me
that we now have-- thanks to a
generous grant, the beginnings
of a database of
searchable articles
in the North Korean serials,
not all of them just a number.
But just the fact that we-- you
can type in keywords, you know,
I'm interested in articles
having to do with agriculture
or with nuclear, you know,
nuclear development or you know,
women's rights or whatever,
you can plug in those keywords
and you will get access to
in a much more focused way.
While as, you know, until now,
it's the good old fashion.
You go in there, you take
out, you know, 50 books
and then you just sit and start
going through them and looking
for a needle in a haystack,
although that's actually--
usually yields a lot of fun
things as I'll talk about later.
You usually find
things by accident.
That's another real
advantage, I think,
to not really knowing
what you're looking for.
So these articles give us
insight into policy, economics,
political, social, historic,
military, legal, financial
and governmental issues.
So it's really, like I
said, a rich, rich archive.
There's something for everyone,
but you have to read Korean.
And as I said, it's
searchable articles right now
from only 18 journals.
What do we say?
We have 274, so this is
just a small sampling
of important journals.
So it's a wonderful beginning.
And if anyone knows of any, you
know, well-intentioned donor
who wants to help us build
this archive then you--
I'll give you Sonya Lee's email
and we can keep working
on that archive.
That database is
extremely important.
OK. So that's, until now,
just kind of introduction
to what we have here at the
Library of Congress which,
you know, it's just a gem for
those of us who are interested
in early North Korean history.
And so a little bit about
how I came to this field.
So in 2007, I was looking
for a dissertation topic.
Those of you who know in
the process of doing a--
getting your PhD,
the all important,
what is my dissertation
going to be, what's going
to be my territory, you
know, my mark in the field.
And I had different ideas.
I kind of came to Korean
studies via circuitous route.
I grew up in New York
and in Israel and my--
was a soldier but I also did
martial arts and I got to Korea.
And I had a lot of
different interests.
I was very curious
about travel literature.
I'll talk a little bit about
that today but as a traveler
and as a person who has kind
of lived in different places,
I was really interested
in how people kind
of understand what
traveling means
and what they're
actually looking at,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I was looking for a different
topic for my dissertation.
But I-- at that time, my
older son was two years old,
and my parents had saved
all my children's books
from when I was young,
when I was very little.
And they brought it over.
I was in Vancouver at the time.
And I was reading my old
books to my children.
And it occurred to me,
my husband is Korean,
and I have a big Korean
family, but it occurred to me
that I knew nothing about
Korean children's literature.
And I was just really
curious what is out there.
So, you know, I just started by
thinking about what's being--
what are published
now, or picture books.
I looked a little bit at-- I
was interested a little bit
in the Korean War and how
that was being portrayed
in children's literature.
But soon enough, I got sucked
into the colonial period
and that was where I spent
the last 10 years thinking
about how children's
literature emerged in Korea
under Japanese colonial rule
which was from 1910 to 1945.
But the first journal
or magazine
for non-adult readers came
out in 1908 so I was really--
became interested in what
children's literature is
in Korea and how it
emerged and how it--
kind of what was
the relationship
between this literature and the,
you know, the following four,
five decades of both
colonial rule
and ideological fracturing
and whatnot.
So I became interested in
literature for children
and that became the topic of
my dissertation and other book
that was published in 2017.
But one day, I was, you know,
I got an email that goes
on to this Korean
studies LISTSERV
and there was an announcement
about a special grant to go
to the Library of Congress
and check out the archives.
And I had not realized
that there were going
to be Korean language materials
in this library and I looked,
you know, I went
into the website.
You know, I was at the
University of British Columbia
in Vancouver, UBC it's called.
And, you know, there's no money
there for graduate students.
So I'm like, someone is
going to give me money
to go check out an archive.
I got to see what this is.
So I went into the
website and I just typed
in children's literature,
Adong Munhak in Korean.
And a page popped up and
there were multiple books
and magazines that showed up.
And I thought, oh, this
is really interesting.
I noticed and I realized
that they were published
in Pyongyang.
And so I thought, oh my
gosh, I hit a goldmine.
I had not heard of this.
You know, the-- You know, no
one that I knew was working
on children's literature.
I never thought that we would
have something on North Korea.
So that was the first time
I came to this library,
went to the Asian reading room.
Sonya at the time and the
other librarians brought
out all these materials.
And it was just, you know,
kind of such an eye-opener.
So that's what I mean,
when you look for something
and you find something
else by accident,
that turns out to be the
really kind of exciting stuff.
And so, see where I am.
So when I came to the Library
of Congress and I was looking
for these materials, this
Adong Munhak magazine,
I at the time was really
interested in the Korean War.
I, you know, just found
it to be such a tragic
but also really fascinating
conflict.
And-- So I was just
interested in--
I guess, growing
up also in Israel
and having my own fair share of
exposure to amounts of conflict,
so I'm just really interested in
how this shows up for children.
And so lo and behold, I found
picture books of all kinds,
both from the 1950s and '60s
in this children's magazine
but also more from the
'80s and even '90s.
And so at this juncture,
I was able to put
together a publication.
It was my first article.
And it helped me understand how
the Korean War has been narrated
in picture books and
fiction for young readers.
And I was trying to understand
how these picture books mobilize
certain sentiments
through these images.
And also, you know, to
try and gauge whether
or not I can read a little
bit of kind of nuance
or resistance or, you know,
not just to read them sort
of top-down, this is the
way you're supposed to think
and nobody would ever think
otherwise but just to try
and see how I can put myself in
the shoes of the readers and see
if I can kind of understand
or find any nuance.
But in any case, I'm
going to share some
of the images with you.
So I was looking for example
at images of South Koreans
and how they were represented as
perhaps, you know, not perhaps,
but groveling and
hapless, and impotent and--
so you know the South
Koreans are painted
in this extremely
negative light.
They are mostly, as you'll
see in this next image,
basically puppets at the
hands of the Americans.
So the Americans of
course are painted
in extremely negative
ways, you know,
with these grotesque features.
They, you know, they
basically just boss
around the South Koreans.
They are morally depraved.
This is one of my
favorite images.
It's actually North Koreans
disguised as South Koreans.
This is really interesting.
And they walk in on the
American base and of course,
there they are drunk with some
kind of cans opened and there's,
you know, the bottle is
surely is kind of, you know,
alcohol and they're sleeping.
And there's a picture,
I love this.
If you'll notice on
the left hand side,
the picture there
seems to be of a nude.
So, you know, all these
ways in which, you know,
the Americans are portrayed in
these very, very negative ways,
and so on and so forth.
So it's really trying
to understand, OK,
how are these images
making their way into the,
let's say national imagination
and how North Koreans are raised
to think about this conflict.
I also became really interested
maybe because of my kind
of morbid sensibility but I
became really interested in just
in portrayals of
violence in general.
You know, and trying to
understand where this was coming
from and what the purpose
of such violent images were.
You know, and of course all
of this is within a context
of you know, this postwar period
in which the United
States reduced North Korea
to rubble with, you
know, constant bombing.
And these images I found or I
argued really helped to sort
of dehumanize the
American enemy.
Desensitize a reader I
think to a certain extent
and really sustain sentiments
of hostility in a context
where there's so
little context, right?
I mean this is-- We're 70
years now after the Korean war
and there has not been-- I mean
there have been hot conflicts
around the DMZ and, you know,
God forbid that there shouldn't
be anything more than that
and hopefully-- or anyway.
So-- but there is-- so
I think that these kinds
of images serve a
certain function of trying
to maintain a kind of, you
know, attitude or stance
when in the absence of a
kind of outright conflict.
And so what I try to show in
some of my early publications is
that the Korean War--
these images from children's
literature really help us
understand how-- you know,
even over 70 years this
conflict can be made meaningful
and feel fresh to
North Koreans who are--
so many of whom are growing
up without living
memory of the war.
And so-- and especially in
light of what you would think
of you know how's children's
literature does tend
to sanitize certain more-- you
know, more difficult content,
I found this to be
extremely interesting.
And I focused in particular on
this one image at the end of one
of the books that I covered
where you have this--
a young North Korean soldier
named Seung-hwan [assumed
spelling] whose picture here
moments before his death.
He survived a torture
that was dealt to him
by these menacing American
captors and their threat is sort
of accentuated by their
darkened shadows behind them,
their faces are so grotesque.
But he has these, you know, rosy
cheeks, this kind of sharp look
in his eye, looking
into the distance.
He's very beautiful.
And so, it's trying to kind of
understand the sort of physical
and spiritual transcendence that
a lot of these images embody
as models for the desire of or
kind of unity and renewal and--
and into the conflict.
And so I argued that
the graphic violence
in North Korean illustrations,
both violence that's dealt
to the enemy and that is
inflicted upon these youngsters
is a, you know, turns them into
martyrs and it becomes part
of this performance where
the ultimate goal is the sort
of regeneration of the
North Korean nation.
So that was one of the
early publications.
But as I was doing this work,
I happen to come
across these images.
They caught my eye and I just
sort of did a double take.
I said, what is this?
And it was really, again,
I wasn't looking
for this material.
I was just kind of focused on
Korean more related materials.
And I found these
images in Adong Munhak,
in the children's magazine.
And yes, this is science
fiction from North Korea.
And so I found that
science fiction narratives--
This led to a publication
that came out in 2014
out of the Journal of Asian
Studies called "Let's go
to the Moon" and I found
that science fiction narratives
set a period in this magazine
from 1955 in translation
from the Russian and then
on from 1956 they have
these original short stories
and longer novels.
And I argued that they bear
witness to certain extent
to the significant
Soviet influence
in the formative period
of the Soviet Union.
But rather than just talk about
these images as imitations
of Soviet materials, you
know, that it's just kind
of a derivative, I tried instead
to locate science
fiction narratives
within North Korean discourses
on children's literature
that was preoccupied
with the role of fiction
as both a reflection
of the real, of reality
and also a projection of
the eminent utopian future.
So through closed readings
of science fiction narratives
from this period, I underscore
the way that science, technology
and the environment
are implicated
in North Korean political
discourses of development
and point to the way in which
these works resolve the inherent
tension between the desirable
and seemingly contradictory
qualities of the ideal scientist
who is both an obedient
servant of the collective
and tireless questioner of
received and accepted truths.
And thus these North
Korean narratives
of science fiction
established the child scientist
as the true kind of protagonist
of the-- of North Korea.
And so I started there
with this publication.
Wanted to just give you
also a taste of some
of the fun findings on the--
on the right had side is
Adong Munhak, a picture of one
of my favorite novels from 1960.
And to the left is a
suspiciously similar image
from 1954 from the
Soviet magazine Pioner.
So you can really see that there
is a borrowing, there is a kind
of intertextual references.
You know, this image on the
right did not credit the image
on the left but you
know, there's--
They're very open
about the relationship
with the Soviet Union and their
interest in exploring you know,
outer space and going into deep
sea exploration and whatnot.
And so, this really kind of
gave me an opportunity to think
about North Korea to
appreciate how truly global
and international North Korea
was in the 1950s and 1960s.
Of course you know, with the
Soviet bloc but, you know,
there was so much exchange,
scientists going back and forth.
That is really just
a fascinating period.
And more recently, I have
looked into some translations.
So I was able to track down--
Actually it started with this
publication on the far right.
This was something I found
in Library of Congress
in my last visit
last May or April,
I don't remember
when I was here.
But it was a short story in
two parts called you know,
"Flight to the Moon" or
"Travel to the Moon" and it said
in very small letters that
it is a Soviet translation
of a Soviet novel.
And so with the help
of a wonderful student
in the Slavic department
at Stanford I was able
to trace both the
original cartoon from 1953
and the 1955 script and
then this translation
from 1956 helped me not
just again not just to say,
oh North Korea is just copying
or it's just a derivative
of Soviet materials, but
to actually look at the way
that the Korean text played
with and changed and, you know,
and tweaked and transformed
the original Russian
to suit its own--
its own purposes.
So you know, again
you don't want--
those of us who do work with
translation, it's always very,
very interesting to
do these comparisons
because you realize that, you
know, of course, you know,
those of us who translate
know this
but translation is
interpretation, right?
I mean these translators are
interpreting the original
and they are making
more, you know,
and making of it
something of their own.
OK, so in the remaining time--
and I do want to leave time for
questions, but I want to share
with you my new project
which I'm really,
really excited about.
This is coming-- again this
is all materials that came
out of the Library of
Congress collection.
And this new article
that is coming
out in September is titled
"Making Science Moral:
The Story of Data in
Postwar North Korea".
So in the-- in 1953, North Korea
was a budding nation seeking
to rebuild itself
from the rubble up.
And it pinned its hopes on
engineers and scientists.
Ambitious goals could be set
but without collective resolve
or the skills necessary to turn
these visions into reality,
these goals were meaningless.
So to this end, the new
government worked quickly
to eradicate illiteracy,
establish a compulsory
education system
and to cultivate
institutions of higher learning.
The injection of foreign capital
from socialist countries
was also instrumental
to North Korea's postwar
development of science
and technology, as
was the integration
of experienced scientist
from overseas including
from South Korea.
The Soviet inspired
[foreign language] or Academy
of Sciences was established
in 1952 in order
to ensure the speedy development
of science and technology
and to centralize its
research activities.
So what I find really
interesting is that at the risk
of stating the obvious,
the scientific--
I'm talking here about science,
the popular science magazines
for young readers
in North Korea.
The scientific is always
framed in ideological terms
but ideology is shot
through with morality.
So ideology in its broadest
terms is a set of conscious
and unconscious political
beliefs that are produced
and reproduced symbolically
and that help preserve power
and dominance of
certain interest groups.
But ideology is inherently
normative,
meaning that ideology
establishes behavioral norms
and guides the way that social
actors make sense of their world
and determine what's
good and evil.
So I set out on this project
to understand the relationship
between the ideological and
the moral through science
and general interest
magazines for Korean youth.
And in this article, I
take note of the manner
in which scientific and--
the scientific and the
ideological content came
to acquire a moral cadence
in these magazines published
in the '50s and '60s.
And so in my article,
I make three arguments.
First, I argue that the moral
landscaping of youth was seen
as vital to North Korea's
future and that science
in general interest
magazines were useful tools
for teaching morality
and restructuring two important
relationships in moral terms,
youth and nature and
youth and community.
And I call this section
"Making Science Moral".
Second, I argue that the
moment that science moves
through language and
is organized in textual
and visual narrative
is the moment
that science becomes
both rhetorically potent
and also potentially volatile.
So I call that section
"The Story of Data".
And third and last I argue
that it is this volatility,
that this volatility was
traced to the youthful mind
or the space of the
imagination or fantasy.
And it was the most illusive
and therefore the most--
or in most urgent
need of restructuring.
And so I call this last section
"Fantasy the Final Frontier".
And so, I mean to show that
it was not just the logic
of ideology but morality
that was invoked in order
to secure a scientific,
political and social utopia.
So as I said, this is based
on these wonderful
materials gathered
from the Library of Congress.
These are just some of the just
wonderful, wonderful covers.
We have four different
magazines here [inaudible]
or Science World
is on the far left.
And then we have [foreign
language] right next
to it, so junior science.
Sonyeondan is-- translates
roughly as boy scouts or scouts.
And then [foreign language]
or new generation
is on the far right.
So the exception of the one on
the far left, [foreign language]
which was aimed, excuse me,
at a general audience
not youth per se.
The other three are aimed
at school-age readers,
middle to high school
and even college.
And so they differ according
to their intended audience,
in their focus, detail,
the number of illustrations,
the overall tone.
But they share an attempt to
turn the specialized knowledge
of science into commonsense.
So [foreign language]
for example, again,
one on the far left, had
monthly features titled "Science
in Everyday Life" or "Science
as Hobby" or "Science is Power".
Some of these also had columns
that were called "Commonsense"
where they try to explain common
social and scientific phenomena.
So in their own words they
attempted to liberate science
from the mystery in which it
was shrouded and to demonstrate
that science was a practical
skill that could be taken
up by anyone, anywhere.
So I'm going to give a couple
of examples now and I think
that what I find that's
really interesting
when I present this material, I
just presented it the other day
at the Association for Asian
Studies, is that there are--
And, you know, I'd be curious
to hear from you as well.
Some of these are really
recognizable to people who grew
up out within South Korea,
maybe the United States as well.
So I think there's a really a
kind of common Cold War culture
that I think emerges
from these magazines
which I think is really
interesting to think about.
So that's why those of us who
study North Korea always have
to study it within the broader
context, both of the Cold War
and the socialist kind of bloc.
But also within, you
know, this divide of both
across the iron curtains
have-- are also looking at--
The way science developed,
for example, in South Korea
and the United States, and there
are many, many similarities.
So for example, in a this
essay "Let Us Raise the Flag
of Science and Move Forward",
the noun science here is
modified by the adjective true.
So here I'm talking
more about how, again,
science becomes couched in
this kind of moral language.
So here's a quote
from this essay.
"Above all we must first study
and learn true science so as
to dedicate all of
our power to it."
Here the author is not referring
to a particular discipline
of science but rather
in approach to science
that involves observation for
the sake of uncovering the laws
of nature that will lead to
social and economic development
that will benefit
the collective.
The essay contrasts the way
that science is practiced
in South Korea, which is for
its own sake, unsystematically,
driven by futile
fantasy, ambition,
superstition and spirits.
By contrast, science in
North Korea is called
"sincere science"
that must be practiced
with a sincere attitude,
tenacity
and with refined
patriotic ideology.
The frequent use of the term
[foreign language] or refined,
refined values, refined
patriotic ideology,
it functions both as aesthetic
and also as a moral term.
Index is a sophisticated
understanding
of social relations and the
unwavering and noble commitment
to advance science
that will bring
about development for everyone.
And I think that that's one of
the things that really comes
out of these materials
if we talk about,
you know, socialist science.
What is being brought up
here is that this is science
that is dedicated
both to improve
or to improve the
quality of life
for everyone not
for a relative few.
And so it's about democratizing
and spreading knowledge
that used to be the privy
of a small elite group,
making science available to
all, but also creating a kind
of development that
will raise everyone
and not just benefit a small,
you know, a number of a--
you know, or this
elite group as I said.
So how did writers themselves
of these magazines
talk about morality?
So in their words, I quote.
"Morality is a set of life
norms that instructs us on how
to behave in the social world,
a set of values that aims
at true liberation
developed by and among worker,
ours is the most progressive and
noble morality in the world."
So, science in general interest
magazines were particularly
useful, I argue, for teaching
morality and more specifically
in restructuring, as I said,
two important relationships
in moral terms, youth and
nature and youth and community.
And I'm going to give you
a couple of examples now.
And I'll try and wrap up soon.
So the restructuring
of the relationship
between the individual
and collective
and moral terms took place
in magazines in the 1950s
and they were reinforced in--
in such sections as this one,
which is called the
"binocular core" or [inaudible]
which was a monthly
section that kind
of through a binocular
spotlight on positive
and negative behavior.
And so you can see here just
from this one example that--
Sorry, this is really
small, that's really small,
I'm sorry about the, you
know, it's hard to see
but I'll hopefully be
able to describe it
to you a little bit more.
But on the left hand side, you
have positive behaviors, right?
And again this is all about how
one should relate to the group
and also how one should relate
or should be in the world.
So it's both interpersonal but
also kind of an environmental--
how to behave with
stuff around you.
So on the left hand side,
you have a positive example
of someone who is treating
communal property with respect,
everyone is cleaning
together and working together.
And on the right hand side,
you have kids sitting on desks
with their legs spread,
their shoes are
on the desk, it's terrible.
Then the one under that, you
have on the left hand side,
instructions that you
should be always walking
on the left had side
of the street.
And then on the right hands
side, you see what happens
when you don't respect the
environment and you don't comply
to that order, you bump
into a really nice halmoni,
a nice grandma who is
just walking on the--
you know, where she needs to be.
And then the bottom most
image, you have, you know,
the caption there
reads, you know,
your desks are not
paralleled bars,
so doing your calisthenics
is very important.
You have that on
the left hand side.
On the right hand side you see
a kid that's fooling around
and not doing what he's
supposed to be doing.
So I find this also interesting
visually where you know,
the right-- the proper behavior
on the left hand side is also,
in terms of the visual
layout is very geometric
and you have the horizontal and
vertical lines and things kind
of are sitting where they
should be sitting in the image.
While as on the right hand side,
you have a lot of vertical--
diagonal lines, you have-- you
have stars, you have squiggles,
you have, you know, the--
you know, all of these are
very disruptive angles.
And so, it's really sort of
illustrating visually this kind
of grammar of order
and disruption.
OK. So up until now-- And
this now is in that magazine,
[foreign language]
new generation
which also had also a
lot of this scientific
and philosophical text.
So until now I'm trying to
show how morality finds its way
into a lot of this
early material.
So, OK, I'm going to try
and go a little bit faster.
So in this section
I talk is called--
the title is "The
Story of Data".
And here I draw more
on narrative theory
which concerns itself with the
relationship between an event
and the representation of
that event in language.
So when we talk about science
writing, I mean this is one
of the really fun things about
this new project that I'm doing,
is that I get a chance to
think about science not just
as presenting representation of
data that is completely stripped
of any kind of linguistic
energy.
That's a kind of maybe fancy
way of saying that, you know,
we tend to think about science
as really just for scientist.
But in fact what we sort--
scholarship has shown is
that even scientist working
on scientific papers and,
you know, or publishing
in scientific journals,
they use language in a way
that is also assuasive,
that also carries
with it certain cultural
assumptions.
And so, therefore we
are justified in looking
at even a seemingly
straightforward article
like this which is,
you know, travel to,
you know, to the universe.
That's talking about the
launch of the satellites
by the soviets in 1962.
It details the experience
of the pilots.
It describes their
daily routines
and it conveys their
personal greetings
to all socialist nations.
So this is a kind of very
straightforward essay.
And so I think, OK,
what can I do with this?
Well, how is this material for
me to study a kind of moral
or assuasive language?
So, sure enough,
you know, I read it
and then there's a
sentence there about how
with this double launch the
soviets have basically left the
Americans in the dust.
And they use this very kind
of strong expression
[foreign language].
You know, it's really sort of
dismissive of the Americans.
And so here you have
instances where seemingly
as I said straightforward
reportage actually has a lot
of this moral and also
ideological language.
And so it helps me kind of
understand how knowledge
about the world is being built.
And so the question that I'm
asking going forward is what
happens when science
passes through language,
when scientific content is
presented in narrative form?
The process of embedding science
and writing both fictional
and nonfiction demands a
moral framing that was central
to North Korea's nation
identity in the 1950s.
Without science and technology,
material recreation would
not have been possible.
And without material
progress, the social
and political projects
would fail.
So it was in the
narratives of magazines
for young North Korean
readers that the scientific
and the moral could
be brought together.
But the power of
language in narrative form
to shape the moral landscape
of young readers is also
what rendered it volatile.
This was because language
open itself to interpretation
and also because
there was a space
into which language did not have
access, and that was the space
of the mind, the
field of imagination.
What they called
[foreign language].
The frontier of the imagination
was the ultimate target
for moral and scientific
narratives
because it proved both the sight
of the greatest hope and also
of the greatest anxiety.
For science and morality
to be effective,
young people's imagination
had to be primed and guided.
and that is my third and final
argument and will I just,
you know, say-- I'll just read
this quote and end with that.
Yi Ki Yong was a very
important writer in north Korea,
writes in 1959 in a
magazine, says the following.
"As the protagonist of
the Chollima generation,
you students must dream big
about the goals of tomorrow.
Spread the wings of fantasy, get
in step with the new generation
of space travelers, and together
take an active role on the stage
of science and creativity."
And so what I show in this
last part of the article,
which is coming out, so you'll
be able to read it, you know,
later, is that there was all
this anxiety about fantasy.
Because fantasy was really
important but because
as I argue with, it's
in the space of the mind
that language and, you
know, that's not reachable.
It was very, very
important to make sure
that fantasy is structured
in imagination
and structured properly.
And so in postliberation
North Korea the urgency
to build a socially cohesive
and technically advanced
country was predicated, I argue,
on the moral structuring
of the young.
Scientific content and science
and literary magazines prove
to be an effective
site for this goal.
In particular the power of
narrative and its mobilization
of language showed itself
to be an effective
conduit of moral behavior.
But the anxiety over the
slippage of language and the pre
or extra linguistics site
of imagination showed itself
to be a persistent
source of concern.
A focus on the narrative
devices that worked
to reshape a moral thought
and to conquer the frontier
of fantasy demonstrates the way
in which the war for science
and technology was waged
with the power of story.
So that is the material that I'm
interested in and just finally--
I have put some images here
of the many, many magazines
that we have here in the Library
of Congress and I will end now
and open the floor for question.
So thank you very
much for listening.
[ Applause ]
Yeah. I'll just take questions.
Yes, sir? Yeah.
>> I would be willing
to bet that North Korea,
with well established
scientists,
are probably more willing to be
engaged in actual communication
with the general population.
In the United States
there has been
in many instances a situation
where really established
scientists are [inaudible]
if they knew that too much.
I think of Carl Sagan who was
a great adviser of science
in our country and was very
effective but according
to some reports was denied
election to the National Academy
of Sciences because even
though subsequently he had the
credential, popularization
aspect have [inaudible].
But I think it's
different with North Korea
but I don't really know.
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
No. That's a great point.
I mean I-- Again, I'm really
focused on the '50s and '60s.
I can't really speak about
contemporary North Korea.
I mean that would
be fascinating but--
So I can't really speak
to how the situation now
but I can only say that indeed,
I mean what makes this period
so interesting is this push for
the popularization of science
and the people that are being
represented, the scholars
that are writing
in these magazines
for young readers
are the president
of Kim Il-sung University.
They are-- They're politicians,
they are community members,
they are teachers,
they're professors.
And so they are writing these
essays for young readers.
So I think that in fact it
is the case that their--
the popularization of
say making science--
giving access to science for all
of the North Korean population,
along with quickly eradicating
illiteracy and getting kids
into schools was
really, really important.
So, thank you for that comment.
Yes?
>> [Inaudible] a couple of
things at the beginning, one,
you're not able to go to the
[inaudible] visit North Korea.
Although there are certain
terms that allow people to go.
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
>> Things like Library
of Congress would have
been into that category.
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
>> But even if you got there and
in connection to the defectors,
obviously many defectors
there are already familiar
with these materials
that you study.
>> Dafna Zur: Right.
>> This come also
from North Korea
and walking out of [inaudible].
>> Dafna Zur: That's right.
>> What is the thoughts on
what exist, it's stored,
and [inaudible] the situation?
It's all three [inaudible]
today.
>> Dafna Zur: Right.
>> Were any of this
information that exist--
Have you heard anything
from other folks [inaudible]
or they've got access to
the material that exist?
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
>> Or is that all
in [inaudible]?
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
Well, you know, I would venture
to guess that the Library
of Congress-- I mean if one day
hopefully there will be peaceful
resolution and, you know,
and North Korea will be open
to this kind of archival
research, I would venture
to guess that what we have
here is probably, you know,
more and better preserved
than what is in North Korea.
And I think that because the
regime has proven to really want
to rewrite and revise
its history based
on who is in power.
And so it wouldn't-- I
wouldn't be surprised if a lot
of this earlier material,
especially this kind of material
that lends itself to
multiplicity of voices.
You can read, you know, the--
I mean this is that what--
what's so exciting about this
period is that you can read
into it ways in which North
Korea is still trying to figure
out what, you know, what some
of the possibilities are.
There's a kind of a polyphony I
would say of ideas and stances
that perhaps would not
fit later on with regime.
So I hope I'm wrong and I hope
that once we do get access
that there's going to
be a wonderful library
where all these materials can
be stored because, you know,
while we have a lot here and
as I'm going to Moscow in May
and I'm hoping to see other
materials that we don't have,
it would be wonderful to
have it all in one place.
But I think that what
we have at the Library
of Congress is probably
the most complete picture
that we will ever get access
too, so-- But I hope I'm wrong.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. So, China and especially
[inaudible], so this is the area
that is across from North
Korea, they also tend
to have a lot of materials.
I'm not sure how strong their
earlier historical material is.
The colleagues that I
collaborate with and work with,
Andre Schmidt from the
University of Toronto
and Suzy Kim from Rutgers and
Charles Armstrong from Columbia,
and others that are
working on North Korea,
[inaudible] Australian National
University, we've all sort
of come to the conclusion
that the materials
at the Library Congress
and Moscow seem
to be among the most complete.
But there are pockets, there
are places, and so that's part
of our job is to kind of figure
out where these places are.
But those seem to be the
"easiest" places to get access.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, right there.
>> Thanks for your presentation.
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
Thank you.
>> So, I'm really fascinated
by the [inaudible]
production in North Korea.
I can get a sense that there's
a wide readership but I'm not--
the idea of [inaudible]
there is really strange
and [inaudible] me.
So, could you give us some
background on, you know,
what your sense of being a
writer in North Korea was then
and how that occupation
has [inaudible].
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah, that's
a great dissertation topic.
So I-- If you want to write
it, I will fully support it.
Yeah. No, this is a
really great question
and it's unfortunately
again, it's one of the--
one of the challenges of working
with an archive like this
that has not been looked
at really anywhere is that,
you know, I don't-- When
I come across these names,
unless they're identified in
the text, I don't know a lot
of the times who
these people are.
And so it's a great question.
And the question of, you
know, who are these writers
or how they came to write
for, you know, what they're--
you know, how the
editing process worked,
how the materials were
circulated, these are all things
that I, at this point,
I'm not able
to really get a good sense of.
I think that-- but I should
say that I have a colleague
at the University of
Binghamton, Immanuel Kim,
who just published a
book out of Hawaii Press
about North Korean literature.
So, it's one of the--
we have two books
on North Korean literature
and his is this brand new one.
He actually has a
relationship with one
of the North Korean authors
that he writes about.
And just the other
day, we were talking.
He was telling us about how
when he traveled to North Korea,
he gets-- he met with
him several times
and he had submitted
questions in advance,
and the author had
responded to the questions.
And when they met in
North Korea in Pyongyang,
they were accompanied
by the minder.
There's-- We always has
these minders that, you know,
are there to make sure that,
you know, the information
that gets passed is,
you know, transparent.
But the author had
apparently typed out 60 pages
of his responses and the
minder just sat there
and Immanuel just went through
and he was deliberately very,
very slow because
he was, you know,
hoping that the guy would
just say, the hell with it,
just take it and read
it on your own time.
But the minder waited.
He sat three and a half
hours with him to go
through every single page.
And so, I think at
this time, you know,
questions about readership
would be much, you know,
much better posed to
my colleague Immanuel,
but it's a great question.
Unfortunately, I don't
have a good answer to it.
I'm sorry.
Yeah. So, did you want
to ask a question?
>> Yes. Thank you so much for
this fascinating presentation.
>> Dafna Zur: Thank you.
>> My question is, to what
extent was international
relations and politics woven
into the moral education.
For example, when they were
promoting, learning science,
did they talk about, you
know, the Soviet Union is
to be respected and
we work them.
Or was it more like,
oh, self-reliance
and Kim Il-sung is god and
you figure that yourself.
You know, what--
>> Dafna Zur: Right.
>> I'm just curious about that.
>> Dafna Zur: Yeah.
No, great question.
So, the reason again I love
working on the '50s and '60s
that it is more of the former
and less of the latter.
And so, absolutely, when
you read the magazines
from the 1950s in North
Korea, it is so international.
There are travels, you know,
all over the Soviet bloc.
There are-- As I said there
are Soviets that are scientists
that come into North Korea.
There are North Koreans
going overseas.
There's so much exchange.
It's so rich.
And so absolutely
there is a sense
that North Korea is
extremely international.
It's a proud-- yeah, proud
part of the socialist bloc
and it is very much kind of up
in step with what is happening
in the Soviet Union
in other countries.
So, the children
that are reading
or the young reading these
magazines are definitely made
to see themselves as a part of a
broader, you know, a broad kind
of republic of socialist
children on the world.
So, yeah. Thank you.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Right. Great question.
And again, you know, I'm not in
a really good place right now
to be able to answer
it completely.
But my understanding from
what I've seen until now,
there are no private
publication.
These are not commercial
enterprises.
These are all public
institutions and the process
of publishing, as it was
in South Korea as well,
is controlled very closely
and there are censorship,
there are multiple steps
in which writers have
to submit their writing.
And so, you know, it's I
would say non-for-profit.
You know, these are magazines
that are looked at very,
very closely and
are-- they're only--
and they're public
or I would say kind
of national publishing houses.
So, you know, again
that's to say
that there is very strict
censorship that is controlled,
but it's also the case for
South Korea where, you know,
especially with the
American military government,
they watched South Korean
publications very closely
to kind of smell out any sort
of pro-communist kind
of, you know, tendencies.
So, you know, they-- I'm
not an expert on this period
of the kind of the publishing
industry as I would like to be
but my sense is that, yes,
the cases that this was--
there was no private publishing.
Sir, in the back, did
you have a question?
[ Inaudible ]
Right.
Right. So, again, you
know, these are things
that I think are a little
bit more difficult to gauge,
barring a kind of more extensive
research on reader reception
in North Korea from
the '50s to '60s.
You can imagine that's a
little bit challenging.
I mean my answer to that is that
we can tell to a certain extent
that there is reader
participation
because you get these-- in every
issue there are always reader
letters that are
sent to the editor.
So, you get voices from
readers and they're always--
they're at-- the place--
The location from which they
are writing and the name
of their school and their
age is written down.
So, you kind see that, oh,
a lot of these magazines are
being picked up by young readers
from all over the
country and so--
But we don't have
circulation numbers.
You know, there's not been
that kind of research done
on these magazines quite yet.
So, I can't say, for
certain, but the--
within the magazine as I read
them, I see that they are kind
of talking about the
importance that they view
in as their materials as
supplementary to school.
So, the sense is that
yes, there are textbooks.
Yeah, the children
are in school,
but these magazines
are meant to kind of--
as enrichment, as
further studying.
And again, with reader
letters that are embedded
in these magazines,
you get a sense
of how broad geographically
these readers are spread out.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. You know what, I
can't really speak now
because my interest sort of--
I've bracketed them at
the 1960s, but my guess--
Oh, and I don't have that
image here as to that.
I have a guide that I know
who is in North Korea,
who works with one
of these tour groups.
And he has recently sent me
this fantastic collection
of postcards from the science--
There's a science center,
like a science world or
whatever in Pyongyang
that is delightful and colorful.
And so, my sense is that
scientific education
and [inaudible] science and
STEM is as important now
in North Korea as
it has ever been.
So, I'm sorry, I
can't take more.
Can I take more questions?
>> Sonya Lee: Sorry.
I feel like I'm a parent
who's trying to send the kids
to bed and, mom, we want
to stay longer, you know.
I feel awful.
But we have to-- we
better wrap it up.
Maybe she will hang
around a few minutes.
>> Dafna Zur: Sure.
Absolutely.
>> Sonya Lee: So, you can ask
later but we have to close up.
So, it's just-- So, thank
you to Dr. Dafna Zur
and share her journey
and then insight with us.
It's so marvelous.
Give--
>> Dafna Zur: Thank you
very much [applause].
Thank you.
>> Sonya Lee: And thanks again
for coming for the event.
Actually I think most
of-- put your name signed.
If you have not, please
do so because that kind
of justify we need to have
this kind of event more often.
Thank you.
Have a wonderful afternoon.
>> Dafna Zur: Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.